tensions remain high in ukraine with
russian troops poised to potentially
invade natalie brandt with the latest
with more than 100 thousand russian
troops amassed near the ukrainian border
cbs news has learned that the biden
administration is considering whether to
send several thousand u.s troops and
equipment to reinforce the eastern flank
of nato but first nato nations would
have to request the assistance
in keeve the state department has
ordered the families of american
diplomats to leave the country they've
advised private u.s citizens to do the
same along with non-essential american
embassy personnel here on capitol hill
there's bipartisan support for ukraine
but some lawmakers are pushing for more
immediate action and sanctions to deter
russia from escalating further
the noose is tightening around ukraine
president zielinski as you mentioned
said he wants the sanctions now
we can always remove the sanctions if it
deters
putin's bad behavior
along the border in ukraine anxious
residents are trying to prepare for a
possible invasion russia insists it has
no intention of doing so instead
president putin blames the u.s and its
allies for ratcheting up tensions by
arming ukraine
what they do is they they twist
reality they are always denying you know
what is what is quite obvious you know
in terms of the the form of aggression
that they're undertaking
for now it's a waiting game with many
convinced it's only a matter of time
before russia acts natalie brandt cbs
news